a woman who accuses Harvey Weinstein of
sexual harassment slammed NBC News
overnight after the company denied
trying to block a damning report about
the disgraced movie mogul former
Weinstein Company employee Emmeline
Astor told the New York Times that she
was prepared to do an on-camera
interview with NBC last year but they
were according to her they told her not
interested last week a former NBC News
producer accused a broadcaster of
killing the Weinstein story
Jericka Duncan has following the
escalating dispute Jericka more people
speaking up good morning the plot
thickens and an internal memo and ten
page report monday NBC News defended its
handling of the Weinstein story and
claimed there was not a single victim or
witness to misconduct by Weinstein
willing to go on the record but reporter
Ronan Farrow is former NBC producer and
now a Weinstein's alleged victim says
that's not true it is not accurate to
say that it was not reportable in fact
there were multiple determinations that
was reportable at NBC journalist Ronan
Farrow is pushing back on claims his
Harvey Weinstein reporting was not ready
for air at NBC News when he presented it
to the network in August of 2017 in a
statement Monday night Farrell wrote
I've avoided commenting on the specifics
of NBC's role to keep the focus on the
women but executives there have now
produced a memo that contains numerous
false or misleading statements it became
increasingly apparent over a very
careful and long process of checking out
these women's claims these are credible
in an internal memo earlier Monday
NBC News Chairman Andy lack defended the
network writing we had nothing yet fit
to broadcast but Farrow did not agree
with that standard but Farrow claimed
Monday his story on Weinstein was twice
cleared and deemed reportable by legal
and standards at NBC only to be blocked
by executives I had spent months and
months in rooms with executives saying
this is not a story you know pack it up
two months after leaving NBC Farrow
published his Pulitzer prize-winning
weinstein report in The New Yorker lacs
said in his memo that NBC wondered then
whether the brave women who spoke to
Pharaoh and
would have also said before TV cameras
and lights in a statement to the New
York Times Monday night Weinstein
accuser Emily Nestor said she and
another woman were willing to go on the
record for the network
she said that portions of the NBC memo
were despicable and dripping with
condescension and she said she was
immensely disappointed by the network's
response but not surprised over many
years many news organizations have
circled this story and faced a great
deal of pressure in doing so last week
Feroz former NBC producer rich McHugh
claimed executives ordered them to stand
down on the Weinstein story altogether
he alleged Weinstein even called NBC
executives directly chairman lacs said
Monday the suggestion Weinstein played a
role in the network's coverage is
baseless speculation Weinstein denies
all accusations of sexual assault
Jericka thank you